okay I welcome to this video I didn't
really start that video properly so
let's try again this ten-second grace
period at the beginning is really used
Chang okay let's see play a quick quick
game here this time I want to lose on
time any game okay we got some BOGO and
I played am a bit of an on theoretical
set up here I just do it like my
opponent do it just cash out some quick
moves without thinking maybe it works
for me as well yeah you never know maybe
that's really the way to succeed and
chest play play some stuff quickly but I
don't don't don't know in blitz I mean
okay okay i take be seven if you want to
take only five or get be seven okay yeah
that's probably an equal ish position
not much going on so maybe night to see
Five trying to poke around a little bit
on the queenside I'm ahead on the clock
ha
so it looks a lot like an endgame queen
a3 is an interesting we are playing ok I
can solidify that Center a little bit
and try to do something like em a
minority attack but it's not so easy
you've got many pieces traded f3 huh ok
I click away 3 has nothing particularly
wrong with that my pawn structure is
sound has nothing no problem I can go to
f 3 f 22 car by III and stuff let's just
play this superdry technical position a
little bit like mr. williger's having
nothing and being happy about it can
still play rook brothers Luke on time
that's an option ok I'm not going to do
that but um playing quickly seemed to
pay off him so let's go here intending a
5 the only thing that could happen that
the position is so close that nothing
much as possible anymore
just can't Ryback for b5 you can go back
to e8 that seems to be the right defense
to that no okay he's giving me the a
file that's nice of him we still has
that counter play but 13 a group B 5
okay so check check here and then let's
take this a file
it's a probably a good defense stinks
that's not happening okay I need to keep
the file let's know nothing to do there
Luke age five was giving him too much
play check each for Butchie eight losses
upon
yeah it's not a very nice position for
him at some it's simply quite passive so
check here check back to see eight can
you go h4 is not ready to be feared I
wouldn't have f4 is a move actually on I
go on and do the rook to g5 probably not
check but what exactly is he doing
where's he going to l'ville I would
think I'm winning one of those pawns
probably King g4 shouldn't be possible
at all check and rook g5 that wins this
pawn yeah maybe that's the way to do it
i play superdry do nothing special and
hope that your opponent gives you some
porn in the rook endgame beer I mean
only gas Windsor half of his games that
way yeah King on the H file was probably
a bit tougher but I don't know it looks
that would have been very passive isn't
that just winning wasn't that the win
when it takes takes King over there King
jou three King age seven then it might
not be a win huh amazing huh
it's not win that's quite peculiar so
age 16 look aged seven that's rather
rather weird time morning amazing
defense look aged seven now it doesn't
really have a draw here thats it's kind
of weird probably has I don't really see
how to avoid it
it's absolutely no way to avoid this
amazing check that's very rare rare that
you can offer offer this kind of this
kind of trade and get away with that
rook h1 rook takes back back there and
check that's not a good idea check gang
humming challenge so Wow chat so we
could actually drive away that porn it's
it's tough to believe text eggs yeah I
h5 is a mistake i believe about stuff I
have to play I looked you one first and
then looks human yeah it's a draw after
work two Cellular's just to draw amazing
I don't know he's moving that that's
pointless it's just a draw yeah it's
just the draw and I have to go rook g1
yent and it's over age 5 and so on
that's it this [ __ ] just has this
miracle defense with the King King a
rook endgame yeah yeah I can also switch
over to the sea pawn that that's a
pretty simple win actually him so oops
sorry it's a bit much check the ok I
played it really like click we can play
simple and stuff and it was quick and it
was simple so well around here white is
always a little bit better because I
have ideas while black has has none so
John it's just a nice position shot wide
which I can i can try forever you
defended well though up to this point
where Jack gave me that porn I think
here my Air Force winning him gently
check that would have been even stronger
that King is pretty much boxed in like
this this and I'm going to win quite
easily yeah but absolutely yeah
absolutely did not I just thought rook
g6 and it's over Andrew g7 is a miracle
and not a miracle defense but it's it's
not happening that often that you can
offer look look trade with being a pawn
down in the end game in the rook endgame
but he did works and it's the only way
to draw very nicely seen at the end that
was the only way to draw otherwise he's
just losing quite um like quite clearly
okay well thanks for watching